[Music]  [Music]  why did you enter this competition I  have to sing a lot of people like to  sing you can missing but you're an  inexperienced performer with a Polish  name entering a competition that relies  on the public vote I never dreamed I  would make it this far  seen from here seen how he's doing he's  not a real manager or anything but he  has a lot for me we can do it not know  it can do this violet  you can do this sink from your heart  I had a way  losing it we would like to offer  violence a contract but you have to sign  up for the shower it's a no-go that's  the deal to the darkest you are to be  [Music]  why me you're a caterpillar we're a  cocoon maybe together we make a  butterfly  [Music]